this morning we're talking all things
tacos with Limelight kitchen Candace
Charles man she always gets the good
jobs she's out there with their ghost
kitchen a live look at this women-owned
operation Candace not only is it
national taco day but it's Taco Tuesday
so this is just perfect
it's right on point Heather and you know
I always got you covered with the fun
stuff as well as making things easier
for yourself now there will be some
deals we're hearing about as well as
freebies throughout the city but why not
try to make tacos yourself for National
Taco day and it's Taco Tuesday I'm
joined by Frank Rizzo she's from
Limelight kitchen as well as Chef
Natalie on the ones and twos or I like
to say the grill and we're gonna go and
talk to you guys really about the simple
way to make tacos I know it's easy right
it should be simple but what is the key
to making the perfect Taco uh so the key
to making the perfect Taco is right now
Limelight kitchen is bringing a fresh
take to Mexican Cuisine we create all
our own sauces we use all the freshest
ingredients and just being creative and
making it so it's lots of fun and
everyone can enjoy it awesome awesome
okay so what is Chef Natalie cooking up
on this side it's all like you said
about being creative and unique when
making these tacos
uh yeah so I mean it's really cool
because the Limelight is trying to
create you know good things for vegan
people good things for
um you know the people who eat meat you
know chicken beef we have really great
ingredients everything is completely
fresh our shrimp taco is one of my
ultimate favorite tacos oh I love shrimp
tacos too so good so um by creating like
our own sauces and our own Pico and
things like that I think it makes it so
it's a lot more fun and it's delicious
and it's a little bit fancier than your
average Taco I like that a little bit
fancier than you have a Chaka okay so
this is cooking up now of course we're
going to give you a sneak peek of it
coming up and then later on in the show
I got you cover what the healthy options
for making a tacos and of course you can
find all the details about the Limelight
Kitchen on our website 8newsnow.com for
now live from there goes Kitchen in
Henderson I'm Candace Charles 8 news now
oh man okay the ones and twos I'm
learning a lot from kids now her dad is
actually a chef so she knows what she's
talking about